this is the iconic opening scene in the
Lion King compared to the original it's
an almost shot-for-shot remake but take
a closer look at Rafiki in the 1994 film
he stands while lifting the cub and in
the new version he since that's because
Rafiki is a mandrill an animal that
couldn't actually stand while lifting a
lion cub striking that balance between
staying true to the original film and
creating a hyper realistically animated
Lion King for a new audience was a
particularly tough challenge and it
required literally millions of hours of
animating the visual effects masters at
MPC film helped animate this ambitious
live-action remake their fingerprints
are all over films that combine live
action and CGI animation from Dumbo to
Detective Pikachu but it was their work
on another Disney remake the jungle book
that really paved the way for what they
were able to achieve with the Lion King
this is Elliot Newman one of the VFX
supervisors on the Lion King if you want
a sense of just how much work Newman in
the MPC film team put into this project
take a look at a few stats
MPC film estimates that there were about
77 million hours of rendering animation
throughout all of their departments if
they used a single computer it would
have taken 8790 years to finish the
movie before they could begin fully
animating they had to actually shoot the
movie and the actors needed to record
their voices instead of just recording
their voices in a sound booth the actors
were actually able to move around as
some teens are recorded in what is
called a black box theater this
bare-bones setup gave the actors room to
interact with the cast and even
improvise some parts though were
recorded in a recording booth Murphy
after what you did
well not motion captured the actors
performances were recorded and used by
animators as a point of reference the
first steps in animation happened in
what's called pre-visualization the
animation team worked with animation
supervisor Andy Jones to create
simplified animated sequences that could
be used for virtual reality this VR
approach onset which they called virtual
production was unique director Jon
Favreau and several crew members would
put on VR headsets which allowed them to
actually step foot in the virtual set
they created this way they could set up
shots adjust lighting and choreographed
movements they treated this digital
environment like a place that really
existed the animals and environments
were created at the same time and rough
versions of the animations could be
viewed on monitors while shooting took
place they would eventually add more
fully realized details and other crucial
aspects like lighting after production
will get more into that later and yes
there were real cameras tracking Timon
and Pumbaa creating the camera movements
in real life rather than just in the
computer allow the filmmakers to create
a nature documentary like feel when it
came to animals they had to tow the fine
line between creating realistic animals
and staying true to the original movie
even though we were making very
realistic with the liens we still needed
to make sure that when you look at
symbol you kind of resonate that that
similar and you understand that that's
the character you're looking at all you
know if you're looking in the faster
than he's got the right visual style for
you to kind of remember that that's you
he is the alpha lion and he's in any
larger than life and he has this
presence of power in the night the
animals were a combination of
storyboards sketches and exhaustive
research Favreau and the team took a
trip to Africa where they observed real
animals and their natural habitats which
helped them build the world plus they
could get up close and personal with a
lot of the animals at Disney's Animal
Kingdom in Orlando Florida they also
read anatomy books and science papers
and watch hours of documentaries and
other reference footage many of the
animals the crew saw in Kenya inspired
the characters for example an excited
lion cub they saw running around as the
rest of the pride slept was a big
influence on how they animated Simba for
some animals making them both realistic
as well as faithful to the original
wasn't easy perhaps the best example of
that is Rafiki if you put them against a
man a real man do you see some group
rafiki's most famous moment comes when
he stands and lifts Simba over his head
for all the pride lands to see as we
mentioned mandrels can't really stand up
like that
however movies shine edited in such a
way that you'll barely notice a
difference because Rafiki is in the
primate family he's the character most
similar to a human therefore they were
able to add some more human-like
qualities and emotions to him the
animators however took some liberties
and occasionally straight from realism
in a few places takes car for example
his design was the furthest from reality
compared to the other Lions but they
made it work here's a lot of physical
qualities that are different from an
actual lion like his size and the shape
of his skull but actually once he was in
the shots and once we've lit things and
we put the environment in and
performances though animates it he was
he worked and every shot he was the best
character we had
animators also had the challenge of
making the animals not only realistic
but able to sing and talk one change
they reposition some animals heads so
the audience would always have to stare
right into their mouths they still had
to make sure their mouths moved how they
did in real life so they time the
characters breathing to their dialogue
Jones said they would let the belly
muscles and diaphragm tighten that way
if felt like a given animal was forcing
air out of its mouth as they spoke each
layer of these animals went through
simulations an additional phase of
animation where skin details such as
muscle ripples skin wrinkles and fur
interaction are all added all of these
details are too complex to hand animate
so they need simulations to generate
them the average first simulation for
instance took eight hours to complete
one of the biggest improvements MPC film
wanted to make since the jungle book was
how they portrayed the layers of each
animal especially their muscles
something has quite common and CG is the
muscles this effect occurs when the
muscles bounce around too much on the
other hand animators also run the risk
of making the characters look too stiff
the problem with that is because there's
a lot of collisions happening under the
skin that's quite big foots in the right
but on the Lion King we we added hard
surface joints bones basically that
those muscles would collide and slide
against and it reduced that kind of that
sort of water balloon movement and even
if we don't notice it there are several
visual factors to making the skin look
just right like how light bounces off of
it and how it moves separate teams
worked on each layer perhaps none being
more important than hair given that
nearly every character in the movie is
covered in it part of the reason they
really had to nail things like muscles
bones and skin is because Alliance hair
is so short that there's less to hide
how the skin and bones move beneath
female lions have even less hair than
their male counterparts and because they
have no Mane's
you can fully see their necks for
characters like Nala they had to add
certain movements to the neck and
esophagus for moments when she's
speaking the male lions have means
which presented their own set of
challenges typically the longer the hair
is the harder it is to simulate 1% of
the whole density of the groom you can
then use that to kind of approximate the
surrounding hairs didn't even quite leaf
ever adult Simba's mane alone consisted
of about 700,000 strands of hair and the
hairs can't just sit still the animation
team created new systems for the Lion
King specifically for gusts of wind
passing through long hair the hairs on a
lion's mane blowing in the wind can be
tricky to control so they made sure the
strands behind the leading hairs in
these shots wouldn't move as much
helping to create a sense that these
animals were covered in layers of hair
well extremely subtle Newman says it's
the kind of specific detail that if not
done correctly the viewer will notice
that it's not kind of level of each
other you have to get to to kind of
reach that part the audience is
believing but sometimes they actually
needed less detail take for example the
infamous wildebeest stampede sequence
the animators started by building up a
big library of animated clips of
wildebeest doing different actions
whether that be walking jumping or
changing direction this allowed them to
more easily create a massive crowd in
motion the wildebeest and the distance
were able to have more simplified
features and could be done by simulation
while they had to animate the wildebeest
that were closer to the camera and thus
more visible to the eye of course the
world surrounding the animals was
equally important they built landscapes
based on many real-life locations in
places like Kenya Namibia and California
another piece of technology they worked
on since the jungle book was what Newman
referred to as a scatter tool it allowed
animators to sprinkle elements across
the surface like twigs leaves and stones
instead of just placing them there one
by one it's a big part of the reason the
Lion King feels so realistic down to
every tiny detail one sequence really
shows off NPCs work creating both the
environments and the animals in them
circle of life is we were working on the
sequence up until the end it's pretty
challenging
there's this kind of it and the
complexities of myself every shot was
funny different as part of your part of
the world like and every tell in an
interview Vanity Fair
Favreau cited an example of a giraffe
bowing during circle of life they would
start with pencil drawings of what they
wanted the action to be against
reference footage of an animal doing a
similar action and then hand animate it
and there were a lot of bowing animals
in that sequence to coordinate and
that's after getting Rafiki to move
correctly the most surprising thing
about this sequences that actually
contains the movies only non CGI shot
Favreau snuck in one real visual which
was captured in Africa
everything from the stones on the ground
to the hairs on Simba to the way Rafiki
moved to the way the cameras captured it
all allowed for an experience in which
the audience felt like they were
stepping into the real life African
savannah while still spending time with
the same animated characters we first
fell in love with back in 1994